Ngày 20% truyền thông gà giấm tinh bố của tổng thống Uquay Nè bố đồ đi Miya Jelensky cho biết, nhà lãnh đảo ngày
bài tỏ mong muốn sống tế hành bầu cử. Chúng tôi cạnh nhận kì của ông đã ký thúc từ ngày 20 năm,
năm 2018 không cho ông Jelensky, điều quan trọng nhất là một cuộc bầu cử có thể tạo cơ hội,
chấm rất súng đồ vàng ngăn đất nước bị triet khát. Chúng tôi gặp tổng thống Mỹ Donald Trump,
hôm 18, ông Jelensky nhấn mạnh điều kiện tiên quyết để tổ chức bầu cử,
là hai bên đàn đường thật thật đương bắn, ông cũng khẳng định sẵn sàng thảo luận chức tế với tổng thống ngà,
là đi Miya Koo Chin, nếu Uquay Nè nhận được những bảo đam anh đến cẩn thiet.
Về khả năng tổ chức đối thải thấp cao, tổng thống Uquay nè cho rằng thủy sĩ án hỏng thuộc như kì,
có thể là những địa điểm vô hợp. Những tuần bố này được dưu lận đánh giá là tính nhiều chính trị quan trọng.
Chưa thấy kìa, vừa tìm tiến sải pháp cho tiến trình chính trị trong nước, vừa đẹn gỏa khả năng ngoại giao,